hey Mr wonderer why am I standing
outside a Richard mill store I wonder if
I'm picking up my first Richard Mill
ever I haven't bought this brand yet I
haven't collected it yet cuz I had a lot
of pops with the size of the watches but
maybe they've got something for me in
there that solves this problem and gets
me on the RM trade watch
[Music]
this
hey Mr Wonder here I'm in a very special
place um this is Richard mil now I
haven't collected meal not one watch yet
and the reason is that they're beautiful
pieces but for a lack of any better
words and this is specifically for Shark
Tank they steal the sh show you know
what that means where the shot where the
director says what is that on your wrist
that's too big it's too explosive bring
it down a notch and for years I kept
showing them ideas cuz I wanted to add
meal to the collection as I like to call
it until you and I met right and while I
was in Japan a few months ago um a
friend of M showed me a mill that was
made out of titanium thin and subtle and
beautiful just and I immed imately took
a picture on his wrist sent it to
wardrobe and said Hey would this work on
shark kick I said we love it get one of
those and today am I getting one of
these yes you're getting one of those
let's start with looking at um a
traditional meal something that they
wouldn't let anywhere okay so first of
all we start with what the brand is yeah
so okay Rich M ised the new brand
compared to the old horological industry
that's true horological industry starts
back in the 1600 unds Mr Mill here yeah
he founded the brand in 1999 right first
watch came out was the in 2001 was the
rm001 monster which by then by those
standards it was pretty it was it's
pretty big pretty thick but also the
technology behind the watch was very
different back that it was all made in
titanium I remember when it came on the
scene a lot of people were talking about
it it had a Frank Mueller vibe to it say
a curve a lot of people said that
um it hadn't exploded into popular
culture yet with sports stars which was
another Direction you guys went and so
you really picked up some momentum with
the whole tennis thing for sure one
round would come up in my collector
Community that's when I first started
hearing about have you heard about Mill
you have a mill you know they're going
into some really crazy dials which
everybody knows I'm a dial guy and I
said yeah but can I a can I get a red
band for TV and B can I wear it on TV
because my attitude is if I can pull
something out of the collection they got
to be able to wear it and I want a
really crazy dial so these early pieces
were big big big watches yeah and and
then going back to where the familiar
Vibes and everything you have to
understand these are shapes in
traditional horology most of the watch
they're round why because the movement
the engines they're round but this is
called a tuno shape Fringe for Barrel
shape Cartier has it a CH has it R me
from
they all share it at that moment FR M
was his hype was most popular brand what
year was this would you we're looking
around early 2000s 2001 this watch came
out in 2001 but then from spored around
2003 2004 and from there you're going to
start seeing how everything derive this
first TR be on movement and Richard M
arm 001 you have spit second knows the
first tural this is this is what the the
the base or let's say the essence of are
turban movements yeah most of in the
collection we also have automatic or
manual one movements non tur on but the
base like what defines R are Turan I
just want to make a point here people
ask me all the time why do you need a
resale store anymore for the watch
industry what we're doing right now
tells you why this is actually the
client's Den if you want to call it that
I'm having a little espresso we're going
through the whole you know chest to get
in the mood in the zone of receiving a
new piece which is always very special
and it it it's a chance for us to
discuss the background on these pieces
and it's very important in the watch
industry wherever I go anywhere in the
world you find rooms like this that cost
a fortune to make even though it's very
hard to get these pieces The Experience
makes it worth it now if I was just
going to get this in a FedEx envelope
that would suck I would rather go
through this experience I don't want it
delivered to my house in a box I want to
live and inhale the experience of that
watch and really enjoy receiving it
that's exactly what we're doing now I'll
try my best
yeah as time go by more watches our
Design This is the r005 first automatic
one right remember that yeah and this
one actually was special it was one of
the first uh ambassadors phip Maza it's
when you started introducing some pretty
Brash colors into the dial that was when
it really started to get interesting and
that was the buzz started to increase
hip-hop culture embraced this big time I
mean I saw it a lot of stars hands and
yet still for me too big couldn't wear
it you know I got a tough crowd in the
television world that just don't want
when you're you're holding up your arm
to steal the show yeah we've been at it
for years until trying to find the
perfect no and you're right you've done
it you've done it that's great look some
other emblematic this are square which a
lot of people don't know on the a far
vibe in that yeah exactly again those
are shapes that already existed in the
watch industry yeah very important watch
R 07 tribun square and then from there
you're GNA start jumping oh I remember
some of these really interesting dials
the crazy stuff started showing up this
is very important to watch turn these
have become very collectible yeah very
today it's a hot that's when you start
getting aftermarket appreciation the big
question with me at the beginning was
what did hold value in the secondary
market and for a while it was a little
shaky that's not the problem today yeah
there's more Brown awareness also big
time you're more exposed to the brand a
lot of people know about it so people
want it probably is that production
doesn't increase that much but that's
always going to be the problem I mean
people want what they can't get that is
the nature of the watch industry it's
the weirdest Dynamic ever you know
that's what happen and you know what a
lot of people get me they criticize me
like okay so why don't you make more
watches and the answer is it's just
impossible it's very difficult well I
know the titanium we're looking at today
very hard to men it's really difficult
you know one one difficult part of that
watch manufacturer is not the movement
itself is the casing in fact the back s
Fem Ming Sapphire to make it so thin
that it fits in the watch it is very
very difficult and the production the
production the rejection in production
is extremely high so maybe a number 20
watches are planned to be made maybe
four five come out I get it I get it
that's been a problem for a lot of
makers fpj had that problem with a lot
of his early dials this is where we
start getting some very interesting
complications on these pieces yeah now
you start seeing T beond So example this
is the arm 21 yeah came out in titanium
first this the base plate is designed
from uh inspiration from aerodynamics in
Airplane this watch appreciated almost
30% right out of the gate about yeah you
don't find them anymore actually and we
just unveiled a new one a new edition of
2201 I'll show it to you came out in a a
combination black carbon white carbon
and titanium yeah so as you see this are
now we going to the what the 27010 27 27
the one which are the Rafa that's when
Rafa came part became part of their I
consider this when you you actually
crescendoed when that that deal happened
which was really a deal on your behalf
and the whole idea that it could take
the tremendous stress the tennis put a
watch under it it would still hold time
and the caliber would remain intact that
was such a hell of a story and I got I
got hand there many story there an
engineer story that they gave the watch
up okay here's your new watch go test it
no problema he goes plays plays with it
then he comes back here's your watch
what happened I don't know it's going
now moving and the watch fell oh yeah no
problem put it back together here try it
again and they did that they did that
they did that onto the watch the G
forces of a Rafa slam must have been
friendable and that's a design behind
the well I think I think that's
absolutely brilliant to do it that way
and then once the word got out that he
could play tennis with it on although I
think he put it on his left
restal and also another another thing is
that there are not many watches in the
watch industry design for this you're
going to see other not not naming names
but you're going to see other players
that go through other big Brands they
play with the watches they play without
the watches and then when the picture
comes up they put the watch right this
guy you know he wears it during the
whole thing fantastic so as you go
progress you know also got round this is
a very important watch in the collection
arm 028 yeah it's a little unusual
people that want the their first or
second meal want the meal look yeah you
know the round is defin that's that's
when you see a what do you okay that's a
rich meal yeah but people are not so so
they not recognize this piece as a
Richard Mill I've seen this piece yeah
it's not easy you have to look at it say
what is that and then you realize Mill
went off piec so to speak and did you
know that a round piece is the one that
Mr Mill was pression I'm sure he is the
only one yeah I get it I get it that he
wears fast forward to today actually the
armman 6701 which is today's
hero Manuel that is the watch I'm
getting that's the watch you and there's
a reason for that it is so beautiful in
terms of the dial and subtle and blends
into the whole stick that I have for
Shar take which is that black suit white
shirt crisp look this marries perfectly
of course it's going to have a red band
I assume yes it does absolutely all
right let's have a look at it well bring
it important to note about this watch
you been the dial it does not have a DI
well it's a skeleton right that's it
yeah that's it and that's a beauty most
most most of the watches unless they are
for all yeah um no but the way the
skeleton is done it's almost a floating
uh image it's it's beautiful I mean what
I've noticed about this watch cuz I saw
it in person the digital image does not
do itjust never it does not do ad
Justice cuz we're going to see it now
and it it's just a whole different
experience I keep saying that I keep
telling that when you see this
renderings trust me when you have the
watch on the wrist is a totally complete
totally different experience yeah let's
see it be back here we go ready
exciting it's always my favorite part
bring out the peace roll the drums
theyve been waiting a long time for this
meal it's taken a long time to get it um
on the other hand you got to wait for
pieces anything
worthwhile you got to wait that's how it
works I will say one thing though it's a
very comfortable piece cuz when I was in
Japan with the FP Jordan society and
these guys are hardcore collectors we
talk about all of our FPS but we also
have a lot of other pieces we travel
with and a lot of people were showcasing
their Mills I didn't have one obviously
and we talked a lot about it but when I
saw I wore this one on my wrist I said
this is the one for me I'll start my
journey into Richard Mill with this
piece cuz it's going to work so well and
you know each year shark take I try and
find nine new pieces there's nine
different watches where I shoot shark
take so you know each year my journey is
the shark take nine where am I going to
find them and this year I'm attempting
to do everything new everything new
every single piece will have never been
on shark tap before that's the challenge
I'm starting right now and so I've got
basically 6 months to pull it off I got
a lot of watches coming but they're all
going to be first time entrance into the
tank all right this is the big reveal
here from Roy yeah absolutely
absolutely
[Music]
wow isn't that
beautiful that's spectacular look at
that of course this this this works so
well with red it's crazy I mean that's
perfect also this titanium is is
beautifully lighted and crisp
it's it's a different when you see it
and then the take that when you take the
watch it's you don't you don't expect it
to be so light beautiful flywheel yeah
very very interesting design on the
flywheel see that amazing remember what
I told to mentioned you about the the
back sigh to Mill that saire so that
wheel the movement is so thin that it
actually comes out of the case into the
space where the sapphire would be you're
kidding so they have to extra Mill the
sapphire and make room for it to spit
yeah and that is extremely difficult
yeah it's
spectacular Let's uh let me set it for
you
sure so this come with a butterfly class
good there like a safety class I can
see right now I canot
guess tell me if it's too tight or not
that's perfect good eye good eye
let's be in large
business wow that's
beautiful absolutely stunning yeah I
mean you can see from 5 yards away it's
a
real
beautiful absolutely
spectacular oh that's nice thank you
very much pleasure boss and you got it
right on time you said you'd get it in
December you got it I tried meaning I
try to keep expectations you know
realistic yeah well I'm going to wear it
that's absolutely
gorgeous okay so setting the date and
time so the watch besides being full
titanium the crown if you notice a crown
it has a function selector as you open
as you turn around
the this isn't very
nice wow that detail is incredible yeah
wow
wdh wdh stand for w winding D date and H
hours so as it we many the crown you
open and close the crown it would shift
into gears Rays numerals are beautiful
yeah it's ni so sh really interesting
fantastic there's a power Reserve here
no it doesn't have that's the that's the
little hand that indicates the the gear
oh no yeah so when you move the crown if
you notice it will it was jump into gear
I see is that a screw down Crown no okay
you open that I see I see so right now
we're at hands yeah that's interesting
yeah that that take
127 o
perfect that's
fantastic well thank you very much my
pleasure this always six first this side
first how and
then and when with time as you close it
you you learn that
too beautiful I didn't even make me too
tight but you told me no it's fine okay
thanks a lot that's my pleasure oh well
that's it I've got my meal and a New
Journey Begins watch for this one on
season 16 of Shark Tank you can't miss
it and of course it's got the Red Band
thank you you did a great job on
this